Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live. I'm your host, Rawkode.
Before we get started, I just wanna take
ten seconds to say thank you to Equinix
Medal. They are my employer,
and they provide the time and resources for
me to put the show together and find
the people to present all of these awesome
cloud native technologies so that we can all
learn together.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
Teleport. Teleport is a application
for providing secure access to servers, Kubernetes, and
applications. And to tell us more about that,
I am joined by
Steven Martin, a solutions engineer for Teleport. Hey,
Steven. How are you? Hi. I'm great, David.
Thanks for having us. Oh, my pleasure.
Do you want to kick us off by
just spending a little bit of time to
first introduce yourself, tell us a little bit
about you, and then we'll talk about what
Teleport is a problem that solves and why
we want it.
Sure.
I and I myself, I joined Teleport,
about a year ago. Most most folks knew
us as Gravitational.
We just recently changed our name to Focal
Fully Teleport as that's our, you know, ongoing
focus, as we've seen a lot of response
in the market.
And myself, I came from, you know, a
mix of
legacy
cloud,
on prem hosted environments,
all kinds of SSH,
Kubernetes, Docker.
And, you know, excited me about joining Teleport
was,
you know, the ability to provide that kind
of access and also in a secure and
audit
auditable way.
And that's what really Teleport is doing is
trying to provide access to resources
that enterprises and individuals,
want,
and making sure that it's, you know, easily
done,
though very secure.
And I think as you go through this,
you'll see, you know, the checks and balances
we have,
to make sure that that that is the
case.
But I, yeah, I can step through a
little die high level of diagram of, you
know, how it works and maybe make it
more clear about what we're doing. Yeah. It'd
be awesome. Okay.
So Wait. Go ahead. Teleport, you know, we're
calling it the unified
access plane,
and, essentially, that's, again, providing that access to
multiple resources.
And as you can see on the right,
you know, we have these set of
typically, your SSH
nodes, those can be, you know, bare metal
machines. Those can be e c two instances,
Google VMs,
you know, whatever you're running,
and we provide those specifically for,
Linux machines.
Also, typically popular is getting access to Kubernetes
clusters.
That could be micro
Kubernetes. That could be EKS,
AKS.
And, you know, we have one of the
most in-depth coverage of that, providing access to
Kubernetes.
And in terms of beyond writing access, we're
also recording activity both for SSH
activity as well as Kubernetes. So whether a
person's getting a list of pods,
executing a session, you know, we can record
it all.
And then lastly, we just added in our
5.0
web application access.
So that's the ability to, you know, provide
either to public URLs or internal URLs.
And, David, you probably have better list of,
you know, those kind of applications to do.
But if you're exposing Grafana,
Jenkins, whatever,
you can now expose that through Teleport.
And the way we secure that is through
using, short lived certificates.
So a user would authenticate
through our proxy that works with the auth
service,
and receive a short lived certificate,
whether they're using that in the web,
or in the command line. And the reason
we specifically went with short lived certificates
instead of some folks were using static keys,
the certificates allow us to designate a time,
which for users is a max of twelve
hours,
as well as other metadata,
you know, what roles and users do they
have, and the other other relevant information
to control their access.
Now when a user connects to a particular
resource,
they go to the proxy. The proxy is
the same Go based Teleport binary running on
the proxy in the auth as well as
in, like, in the node and Kubernetes cluster
access.
And, essentially,
you know, they pass through the proxy.
The proxy confirms,
going through the auth to the node,
and they're they're allowed in. So it's a
very secure environment,
and it go there's a way with, you
know, static keys or ways that people could
potentially,
you know, circumvent environments or use keys that
have been laying around for years. And we
think this is this is the best way
to go for these kind of resources.
In the case of Kubernetes,
you know, beyond what you typically do with
SSH,
we have a number of ways you can
access. We can have the kube config from
the cluster. We can run, you know, as
I think we're gonna do today, David, is,
you know, run a service within the cluster
that allows access,
and really try to provide multiple ways to
give that access.
And lastly, with the with the web app,
you can have a Teleport agent that runs
within,
a single deployment or outside that's connecting in
and providing that web app access.
And that's really, again, to allow you to
connect to services that may not always be
publicly available or directly available,
from the user's environment.
And then all of this is tracked in
terms of, you know, when these access happen,
tracking an audit log. You can control the
number of connections people have the nodes. You
know, there's a whole host of detailed connect
configurations you can do. But often, it's you
know, the best thing is you can get
this up and going, you know, very shortly.
Nice. Yeah. I was actually going through the
documentation, and I said earlier, and I was
trying to, you know, equate it to tools
that I'm familiar with from my past. You
know? And the first thing when I see
an SSH and the server access was to
go, it's like a jump box or a
bastion box that gives me a way to
secure
and restrict access to my customers which we
all want. We all want better security and
then it later done the Kubernetes stuff and
I was oh, this is getting quite interesting
and then the the web app one that
was this like wow because
so many times just in the last three
months alone,
I like to build static sites from YAML
files and get and then host them as
websites and like JavaScript
things.
They never come without any authentication because it's
just a static site and I do this
for loads of internal stuff within Equinix Medal
and I end up sticking NGINX in front
of it was like this really crappy basic
off just to try and keep it a
little bit secure even though it's not really
secure and I thought this could be what
I need inside of our clusters or bare
metal machines to just actually secure that in
a slightly better fashion. So I'm really excited
to see how this is gonna work out
today.
Yeah. Great.
Alright. Is there anything else you wanna share
or should we get over to my screen
and No. Let's let's get into it and
I think we'll, you know, we'll discuss more
of the technical as we go. Alright. Awesome.
Cool. So
one of the things I'm really
I advocate a lot in this show is
I don't really wanna do anything upfront, but
at the same time, I also don't want
people sitting watching me spin up a Kubernetes
cluster. So
what I have done is I got a
six node Kubernetes cluster, three control planes, three
working on. Hopefully, that should be enough for
us to play around with us today and
just in case we need it or if
we choose to do this first, I've also
got just a standard machine running Ubuntu as
well. Not a Kubernetes cluster which we could
play with I
also have access to the documentation
here
and I believe today
are we going through the getting started guide?
Yes. Right. Okay. So quick start.
The website for anyone who wants to check
us out in their own time which is
goteleport.com.
So let's see.
Do you wanna start
with Ubuntu box or do you wanna go
straight to the Kubernetes box? Do have that?
Start with the Ubuntu
because I I you certainly could do it
on Kubernetes.
I think it's gonna be a little more
straightforward to see it from the the Teleport
instance.
Alright. Let's just get myself on this.
Alright.
Easy.
So
the easiest way to get this installed is
just gonna be the Linux tarpaul. Alright?
Hopefully, it's nice and fast. There we go.
Did that do it? It did. Yep. You're
you've you've got installed, so you do a
Teleport version, and let's see what
have Well, that
I was messing around with my transparency earlier,
and now that's really painful to read.
Now we can I I would like to
come back and probably make this a Linux
service as that system d has?
But before that, we can continue with the
other steps and then
do the configuration.
Okay. No problem. So
let's just cut this and then I'll go
through it.
So
I'm struggling to talk and type. Is so
cold in Scotland today.
So I think and and this is the
point, when we'd want to decide
what public address. We wanna put here the
DNS entry.
So that proxy service, that's where you put
the
the DNS.
Okay. So down here? Yeah.
Alright. Is this in the docs or am
I just I think there's a if you
go down a little further, I think it
has it.
Alright. So
Yeah. See that public address part?
So we we can use those instructions. I
think I was jumping a little bit ahead
Alright. Because well, because of the TLS part.
So that's why I was saying it's good
for us to decide,
what we wanna what DNS entry we wanna
use for this.
Okay. Well, let's get that in the right
directory.
Okay. Now it's telling me I wanna set
up.
And it's giving you you see that the
the DNS while yeah. It's using it's doing
a wildcard
certs there.
Yes.
Now I barely just grab cert bot.
Software
on.
I think
Oh, there we go.
Do I need to pick something here?
Yeah. Command lane. That's what I want. Okay.
It's telling me what command lane means. Oh,
there we go.
Snap.
Do I really need to snap it?
Let's just see. App to update.
There we go.
Maybe.
Yes. There we go.
Okay. So we just want to generate some
certificates
and
use the correct DNS names. So Yep.
We're just gonna use
the NetBIOS
service. So I just need the IP address
of this machine again
and format it with
oh, it doesn't matter if it's dashes or
dots. Perfect. Okay. We'll do dashes so that
we can
do this.
And then we'll do the star version.
I don't know if cert bot will complain
at me if I don't update this too.
Did I break it?
I haven't gone from rendered again.
It's took off the
I I knew that I should have just
put that into a file and modified it.
I I sometimes do that. Yeah.
Alright. Let's do that again. So
I need my IP address.
So where are you joining me from today,
Steven? I live outside of Annapolis, Maryland.
And what's the weather like for you?
We're we're getting into winter, so we're we're
seeing the forties and fifties. I think today
it's a little warmer.
Yeah. We are just below freezing today and
this office is not is not good at
containing heat anyway. I'm sitting here literally
shipping in and shaking, but
unrecognized
arguments.
I'm gonna put this into a fail.
And maybe that slash
there.
Yep. You're correct,
I think.
Getting tripped up by Sherpa. Okay. Command.
So that looks okay. Let's go along, make
sure there's no weird new lanes.
Change this.
Oh, there's commands here twice. Emails. I don't
know if that makes a difference, but oh,
I see. Oh, it oh, got in there
twice. How weird.
Yeah.
Right. Okay. So
well, that is really weird. Right.
So cert bot let me just make sure
I got this right.
Cert only before the manual. Right. We're good
now. Yeah. I'm seeing this with confidence.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay. We don't we actually,
we can do it without it and then
I can because it it's we can go
insecure.
Okay. Yeah. Alright.
That's annoying. That would've been good. So
so what what does that mean then for
Teleport? Is it it's just gonna be serving
over regular HTTP?
It it'll automatically generate
a
self signed
key TLS,
and then and then you can you can
still connect to it from the command line
or the web. You'll simply have to confirm
it.
In this case, you know, I I don't
believe you can use the the application part,
but I can demo that myself and just
show you some examples. Oh, yeah. That would
be cool. Okay. Let's do that.
Yeah. So that's one rep that's a one
place you do need the TLSI link. But,
otherwise, it's we we try to make it
so you can still use it. We we,
of course, wouldn't recommend that in production. But
Okay.
Alright. So I need the IP address again.
Alright.
Nip.
Yeah. I've been bitten by that less encrypt
limit before.
Yeah. I I've never actually tried to do
it before for an IP address. Just thought
it would be okay. Do you wanna go
in and remove those those key pairs?
Because it'll it'll generate it for us.
Gotcha.
So if those are missing, it does a
self signed certificate.
Yes. And I think we wanna line up
it may not matter, but may wanna
yeah. Just move yeah. It's fine.
Alright. Let's see. So we don't have a
system to service, do we? We just installed
a That's where I wanted to go. If
you go into the examples part of the
when you extracted the tar,
there'll be an example of a Teleport service.
Example system d.
K. So we just copy this teleport.service
here.
Daemon reload
and restart Teleport.
Okay to go? Yeah. It should should be
running.
You can and then we could let yeah.
Let's check the status. Or or you already
did? You already did?
Or you We we can check the status
explicitly, but it seems to be it seems
to be running. Yeah. There we go. Active
and running. So So why why don't we
see if
from from the web, let's see if we
can access that site, and then we can
create it then we'll create a user.
Okay.
So Teleport runs a web interface?
Yes. On port thirty eighty.
On port thirty eighty.
And it's secure.
There we go.
Yeah. Chrome gets a bit funny with those.
Yeah. We may may may may need we
use Safari.
I don't think I've ever opened Safari before.
Alright.
View this
set.
Are you sure you're sure?
Wow.
There we go.
Alright. We made it. Okay.
We don't we don't have a user yet,
and let's go back to the command line,
and we can and I can show you
how to create one. Okay. So run
t CTL
or t what we call t cuddle.
Yep.
So t cuddle is essentially your, you know
that that's your command line tool to interface
with the actual settings within Teleport.
And you can do things like step like
t cuddle status.
So in there, you'll see the CA pin.
So as part of that installation,
it went ahead and generated a certificate.
And there you can see the CA pin.
So when you do things like install to
a node,
two things are done there. One is if
you if you saw on the Teleport YAML,
there was a token
that was part that was listed.
And so that token is gonna be used
by the nodes or other services to register
themselves
with the auth service.
Now as you can imagine,
that's just like regular SSH.
Okay. Well, if I SSH in to a
machine and give a password,
well, I then I'm then I in a
lot of cases, you then trust that machine.
Right?
If you use the CA pin as well,
if you do a Teleport configure I'll I'll
show you where it's set.
So if you scroll up a bit,
see that CA pin?
Yep. Here. Yep. So you would take that
same CA pin, and you would put you
can see the auth token is there.
I'm pointing at a different location.
You can see it has the auth token,
the auth server,
and then the CA pin. So that's that's
a secure way
of connecting in.
And tokens can either be dynamic or static.
For production, we'd recommend using that dynamic
and periodically pulling down the latest token.
You can always use static as well.
If you in this case, it's the thirty
twenty five is the default off service port.
You can also point at the thirty eighty,
the same as the web uses, and that
will use a reverse tunnel. So then you
don't need to expose a port on the
SSH node.
Okay. So just so I understand what's happened
here. When we downloaded the Teleport binary, created
the system d service and started it.
Teleport is running a web interface, which I'm
assuming has some admin functions. It runs on
off service,
and it runs on SSH server. Is that
right?
An SSH service. Yes. And that sits by
d it doesn't have it here, but that
sits by default on port thirty twenty two
Mhmm. Or uses the reverse tunnel approach and
doesn't have to expose a port. And we
use thirty twenty two because SSH is 22.
So is it common practice for Teleport customers,
once they have Teleport running on their infrastructure
to just uninstall open SSH and just remove
that from existence? So some completely uninstall it.
We do have
clients who will
they'll have it start up briefly
on the machine and then shut down just
just in case they want to keep that.
So everyone has a a different preference there.
I think, you know, most most would make
Teleport their primary
interaction.
Now the what you've done when you've installed
it this way,
it's it's storing its configuration.
And if you go into the Varlib Teleport
directory
So this
this is using a local directory storage. So
we have things like a back end directory,
a cache,
and that's and then those those TLS
self signed TLS, as I mentioned, those are
generated here. So this is an example of
a local directory storage.
If we used,
either etcd
or,
DynamoDB
or the Google Firestore, you would not see
the back end, for example. So those would
be stored off. And in this case, you
have a proxy off and SSH on one
machine.
As you in the diagram I showed,
you saw that it would separate out, and
you would typically have a different node running
each of those services.
And we have, you know, we have that
full details on our documentation,
you know, in terms of a high availability
kind of configuration.
But the good thing is you can get
this up and going quickly.
And then from here, we can we can
go ahead and create a user to get
you in.
Alright. So
users
We go back to the
the instructions you're in. I think I had
a little bit more info on that.
Oh, yeah. The docs. Our friendly
I'm busy going off script there. Yeah. Yeah.
Alright. So
okay. Let's do this.
So he yeah. Here'd be good to know
on your other
machines what users you'd wanna go in, whether
you wanna I don't know if you have
a David user or, you know, what what's
your typical usernames you use on those other
machines?
So all the machines are only have a
a root user at the moment.
Okay.
So I should just be doing
root?
You can do root you can add other
users,
and I can show you how it can
automatically
add users.
Okay. So this first parameter here to users
add is my Teleport username for logging in
to the admin interface, and then this is
the users on the other on the servers
that I want to support?
Yes. Exactly. So that user would have access
to that.
We'll also come back. Let's go ahead and
create this, and I'll show you in a
bit
how we will update it for your Kubernetes
setting as well.
Opened in the wrong browser.
Let's get Safari back.
Alright.
My two factor talk? Oh, I have to
scan the thing. Yeah.
Okay.
I just have one password to it then.
Sure.
Save it.
Teleport.
And that should allow me to
choose a button here, right, for scanning a
thing. Oh, yes.
No.
I I I tend to use my phone,
but I, yeah, I thought there was a
way to do that. Yeah. There I'll just
do I'll use my phone.
The Teleport is pretty secure by default then
if it's
That you can disable that, but it's on
by default.
And there's other options like, you know, UTF,
the UV key thing.
We've also if we have time, I'll show
know, there's an option for using, like, Duo
when you go into a node,
in addition to this initial, you know, user
authentication.
I'm in. There we go.
Okay. So what you're seeing now is
that SSH
note the SSH service for your that is
part of that one installation.
Typically, when you have your full
you wouldn't expose the SSH on that. But
for initial startup, that's that's very typical.
And then if you connect,
you can open up a a session there.
Okay. Let's
I've got my choice of user. So let's
just do it.
Cool.
What happens if I try Rawkode? Will it
fail?
Yeah. Okay. And on user and then and
then well, let's go look at the activity
so we can see what's been happening.
And we can see the session we can
see the session then session recordings
so you can replay.
Ah,
k.
And you can move that back and forth.
You should be able to copy and you
should be able to select the text. Woah.
Hey. Is that great?
That's not a video.
Yeah. Yeah. No. It it plays like that.
And it will if you have, like, a
twenty minute hour long session and it's idle,
it will skip ahead in a replay, but
it's still recording.
Yeah. That's a that's a big feature people
I'm gonna I'm gonna need a minute to
process this. That's
wild.
Yeah. If you go if you if you
go back in and, like, do a top
and, you know, or h top, whatever colors,
it'll it'll show. Looks just like whatever you
see.
Okay.
Let's do that again. Yeah. Let's do
In fact, I'm curious now. So hold on.
Let's do two. So if I do read
the
what's is there not a password flag on
read?
I was wondering if if if I have
to take the input of Teleport which I
know about it and I thought it was
dash p.
It's not important.
A prompt. Let's
see.
No. Alright. Never mind. Okay. So let's try
the htop recorded session. So how is that
working? Oh, that's the red one. I mean,
I seen on the documentation when I was
having a look earlier.
I mentioned e b p f. Is that
what's powering this or is it That because
I'm going through the the terminal session. If
I ask the session normally, does that still
get recorded as a session?
You the the so there are various options
for that.
If
you're
the what by default, it's gonna record
the session text you do, whether colors and
everything, just put all the characters.
There is the option to use EPF,
and maybe we wanna go back to the
we can go back to the documentation.
We can highlight a couple things there.
Okay. And and I don't know if you
answered that there, I I was still confused
and shocked at how awesome that was. If
I SSHN normally, does that get recorded as
a session, or is it only going through
the SSH service? Oh, it it would be
recorded.
The difference is when you set up an
open SSH
server,
which can still be recorded, there's just a
little bit of a different setting.
For SSH,
we would have to set up if you
go there is on our documentation, there is
a method on how you do SSH. Alright.
Okay. So that's something I would enable afterwards
then. Oh, you I mean, you could do
it quickly, but it it it the difference
is you have to send in
you're using the certificate that's been issued locally,
and and, yeah, yeah, this is a good
point to use your command line,
but you're using a local issue
certificate to authenticate yourself. So the SSH has
to has to also present that, which our
TSH does automatically.
Okay. Nice.
And, yeah, the audit log is gonna I
mean, it's gonna have the session, but it's
also gonna have all of the you know,
when do you start, when did you disconnect.
If you enabled,
the
eBPF,
then you would see every command here as
well that people are running.
Wow. That's pretty cool.
I'm always impressed by stuff to integrate eBPF
into the technologies because it just seems so
cutting. Well, I mean, it is cutting edge.
Yeah. And and people can you know, if
you obfuscate, if you
doing net if you're doing weird network stuff,
it's gonna catch that. So it it is
very helpful for those kind of environments.
Okay.
Should we go back to our our guide
then? I mean, we're we've only executed, like,
half of this getting started thing, haven't we?
And I'm already just like, wow. So let's
see what else comes. Yeah.
So we did the user.
We looked at the note. Okay. So this
is just walking through some of the stuff.
Yeah. This is this would be a good
point to get a a local client,
the TSH.
Okay. Do I have this command? Is that
something I have to If it's on your
Mac, you'd want to get yeah. You'd wanna
get the the actual TSH client.
MacOS.
I'm not sure what the difference between these
is. So I just click.
So this is just a Teleport SSH client
for Yeah. My command line access. Alright. Got
it.
Alright. I think that's installed.
Let's go.
Oh, where's the docs?
Copy this.
And then you'd wanna do that in your
own Yeah. Yeah. Oh, is that your local
environment?
This bottom one is now.
Although I lost my paste buffer. There we
go.
Okay.
So we need
147Dash7532.
I wish I had prepared a nice DNS
name in advance now.
And I called my username Rawkode.
And we do we do because it's running
insecure, we need to pass in the command
dash dash insecure.
Does dash k work with curl?
No.
There's a feature request. Oh, sure. Yeah. Oh,
that's kinda good.
So the same password you put in wait.
Yeah. You copy maybe copy it from there.
Yeah. It was randomly generated.
I flashed my password enough on the stream
now. So
And now if you do, type t s
h.
Just, yeah, just t s h so we
can look at the options.
So
this gives you and and we'll come back
to this for the Kubernetes part.
But you can see the
the SSH,
so then we connect to a node.
Typically, you use, like, LS to list the
nodes that are available.
You can join an active session. That'll that'll
be something, I think, good
that we can show there,
SCP,
navigating clusters.
So a cluster
is in this case, you've installed one Teleport
instance.
Mhmm. And then that has nodes, Kubernetes applications
that are available. In a lot of cases,
there's a reason just to install
another Teleport instance that has its own set
of SSH nodes,
apps, and Kubernetes,
but then you want to be able to
access that.
And and you that other instance can trust
back to your instance,
map its roles, and the user can then
go through
that Teleport that root Teleport instance to get
access to those resources.
Alright.
Yeah.
Fun stuff.
Yeah. Yeah. Definitely. And and that uses reverse
tunneling. Usually, it's in case of either a
network issue
of why they wanna do that or regional
based. You know, if you're Eastern Western US
or Europe,
you know, you don't necessarily want one instance
having
all thousands of the SSH nodes or something.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
So what what should I be? Yeah. Let's
let's do a t s h l s
so we can see the nodes that are
available.
And then just s s h entered.
We have to use the the root at.
I'll try dashing on there.
Okay. Cool. And
now if you go if you go back
to the webs the app the web version
of it.
Yep.
Oh, okay. Active sessions. You can join that
session.
And if you put if you wanna overlay
them, if that's possible
Yes. Whatever you type, they'll see whatever they
type, you'll you'll see.
Yeah. It's fine.
See, I'm I'm still But
if you as you go back and forth,
you'll see that, you know, it's the same
view.
I'm still learning how to Mac. I'm a
Linux user, like, a forced I
I I keep giving the option to do
Mac, and I've I've I've stuck with Linux
PCs for now. Alright. So I think I
should now be able to yeah. There we
go. Okay. So
There you go. And you notice that number
two in the upper left?
So you can hover over that
on the on the on the web.
Oh, yeah. Oh, okay. So that's telling you
there's two people in the system. If you
go back if you go back to the
sessions tab,
if you look at the audit log,
it'll it'll
indicate that someone else has joined. So all
that's being tracked.
Whether or not the session's being recorded, which
is something you can turn off, you don't
have to have session recordings.
Some of our clients decide to disable that.
They're more worried about just access,
and they don't necessarily wanna record the sessions.
But you're still getting those events recorded. So
each of those are events. You know, who's
joined, where did they join from,
because each of you are individual logins that
are being tracked.
So, you know, when,
you know, when we talk about security,
like, it's normally much more something we can
there's usually tell when something's been breached about
understanding and doing the
the detective work to work out what was
compromised can be really difficult. And I can
see why session recording here can actually get
people they say, oh, this is, you know,
they go in through here and this is
all the files they accessed.
When we enable the BPF integration,
do we have the ability to restrict what
is audited? Like, can we just say, oh,
this is the file that was opened rather
than the actual full playback or can we
see
just a list of the commands? Like or
do you need to do the recording? How
does that kinda work together?
The the so the the will
log
to
the audit log, the act the individual commands,
network, and file activity. Those are three options
that you can log.
It doesn't actually restrict the commands,
but that can be fed in real time
to, like, an Elastic or Splunk,
and you could have something monitoring for that.
I'd say the other option that people and
we just released this as well,
is limiting the number of connections you have.
So you can restrict how many connection like,
you could just say five max connections
based on their role.
And that way, you're you're both you're monitoring
at that, but then you're being proactive and
saying, well, if someone compromised you,
then you can't they can't just explode and
do a hundred connections across all of your
nodes and then start downloading things or, you
know, altering data. So those are some of
the active productions.
I'd say in terms of, you know, monitoring
and usage, that's where, yeah, we would have
people
doing real time
controls through their Splunk or Elastic and then
alerting admins.
And it's pretty it's one of the things
I did was I set up an Elastic
service
that my app service sits in front of
and gives me access to that Elastic. So
I don't expose that. I don't I don't
wanna go through all the all all the
controls of Elastic, but then I run that
behind it, and then my Teleport actually exposes
that.
Nice. Something you could do.
Alright.
So we got this going, and we can
we can close that we can close those
sessions, and then maybe you wanna add one
of those other nodes.
Yeah. Sure. Okay.
So
it's just
SSH into this one.
Yeah.
There we go.
So we're just gonna install
Teleport on this one the same way we
did before?
Yeah. We can just we can download it
and just run the install.
And I'll I'll show you. There's a there's
a quick way to to get it up
and
running.
Alright. So it did the downloaded thing.
CD in there.
And do we still run install again? Yep.
Yes. Okay.
And then from if you go back to
the
proxy auth,
and you can do it in here or
or from the SSH already had opened.
Oh, alright. Okay. I gotcha. So from here.
And then run that run t cuddle again,
and we'll see the list of commands.
Yep.
So there's a t cuddle nodes add.
That.
Now we just wanna make sure that that's
the IP that you think it can reach
that, or does it we might need to
change that to the the DNS entry. No.
It's okay. I can go over the private
network. Okay.
And you're off.
That's it. Go back if we go back
to the web service, it should should be
available.
Okay.
There we go.
Yeah. That's too cool.
Yep.
Yeah. It's I mean, that's that's the fast
that's the fastest way to do it.
You know, it's typically, you'd also have like,
if you notice that there's a labeling for
the
the Teleport Linux one.
So often you would have you'd use that
Teleport YAML, put in the SSH service,
and then you could also and then you
can also put in things like our PAM
control, our PAM configuration to automatically like, you
can create users or other kind of things
like setting up, you know, dual integration, things
like that. So there's a you know, you
start off very small, and then you can,
you know, quickly do all these hoops and
things that people wanna do.
Alright. I like it. Mhmm.
What do you wanna do next, Toby? Is
there more on this quick start? Let's see.
I think
that's most of it. I think the
you know, from here, I think for SSH,
you would tip and I think they're doing
the same thing there. Let me go back
go up a little bit.
Okay. Oh, the one thing I didn't oh,
so that's a that's a good example they
have there on that Teleport start
where they actually show you can put a
label in.
So you could've you could've put a label
in there,
directly as well. So that's very helpful.
And those labels could be things like,
what region my machine is in, what its
use case is, who the owner is, what
just any arbitrary key value pairs I want.
Well, if if we go back to the
to the TSH command line, you can use
that to search for nodes.
So from your Oh, from my machine. Okay.
Yeah. Your your machine.
Is there a search command? Oh, I'm sorry.
The l s. When you do l s
t s h l s.
And if you do t s h l
s environment equal staging, it should only return
that one line.
Okay.
Cool. Yeah. And you can actually you you
can use that to also open an SSH
session. So you could say, go find me
this, you know, label. Maybe maybe instead you
used a
you used a ID like, machine ID,
you know, addition. That's usually what I do
is I have machine ID,
the environment, and then some any other relevant
information.
Alright. Very cool. Yeah.
Which one what what do we what do
we do next? I think the the Kubernetes
setup would be good.
Alright.
So let's see.
So
there we go. Okay. Yep.
Helm repo ads.
We don't need these other machines anymore, do
we? If I just close these tabs so
I don't get too confused. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm easily confused. Oh, I know. It it
it adds up.
That it's Oh, I'm actually wanted the in
terms of the
getting access to that Kubernetes,
I I wanted to deploy it through one
of our other
charts,
which if you pull if you go to
our our I I think this is not
yet out yet. So what
unless you go go to the multiple Kubernetes
clusters.
I think there's on the right. Oh, yep.
That's
fine.
That's,
yeah. Let's let's do,
oh, I I yeah. That that. So there's
if you go to our GitHub,
I'll show you the the the chart, I
I mean. Is it GoTeleport?
Grab so gravitational. Gravitational. Gravitational.
It'll it'll change eventually.
Teleport,
that'll come up. First one.
And then go if you go into oh,
look. There I am. I just added something.
And you go to examples,
chart,
and then the Teleport,
cube agent.
So I should probably clone this down?
Yes. And then the one other thing we'll
have to add a Cube token. Right now,
we do not have a Cube token.
Alright. Let's grab this first.
And what?
Teleport examples
chart.
Teleport
cube agent. Alright.
Always goes to the wrong window. So let's
get the read me which had an install
command.
And we need to drop a few things
in here. So
can these just be done through values fail?
Yes.
Okay.
So this off token is just a join
token. Right? Yes. And in in our
if you go back to our service, we'll
we'll wanna add a new line of a
a cube token.
Right right now, it does not. It only
has app proxy and node.
So we need to go back to
the existing Teleport that we set up? Yes.
On the
or via the UI?
We can do either way.
Oh, I'm sorry. No. From here, you'd have
to open up an SSH session to do
it. Yeah.
Unfortunately, that's trivial now. So
Yeah. If you do that you can do
it remotely,
but I I was
through a t cuddle.
Oh, yep. Oh, you know what you're doing?
So the yeah. The if we do a
t cuddle if we do a t cuddle
tokens l s,
You can see we don't we don't have
a queue one.
So if we go into the
Etsy Teleport YAML, we can add a new
queue line.
Alright.
So is that just a new service here?
Or or is that a token here? Yeah.
Yeah. Just dash
cube
colon
and then a then a token.
And that's the join token from my Kubernetes
cluster? Yes. For the yeah.
Because you're basic you can basically give different
types of
tokens. You don't you don't always want them
to be the same the same.
Alright. Let me just jump onto one of
these machines and grab that then.
Curl.
There should be a join token available in
the metadata.
I know the user data. Oh oh, usually
just make it up. It doesn't or or
have it generate
one through a
randomizer.
Oh, so it's not actually a real No.
No. I'm sorry. Not not that. No. It's
it's just it's a it's a random
ID, like a password.
Alright. Okay. Thought you actually went to the
cube ADM No. No. No. That that is
good distinction. No. That that does not have
to be related to that.
Alright.
Okay. So
let's come back over here and I can
enter
like so. Yeah. Sure.
But a b c of one two three
work. Does this maybe overkill?
Yeah.
Alright. Let's save that. Do I need to
restart Teleport?
In order to tell it can be found.
Yeah. It'll probably it might kick you out
of the web, but let's it'll probably that's
fine.
Yeah. Okay.
But but then then right back up.
And
we ran TCTL tokens LS.
Okay. Now we have a cube token. Yep.
Okay. So that has to go into our
Helm chart
here.
The proxy address, is that the same IP
address that we're browsing to? Yes. With with
the 3080.
With the 3080.
And you you don't need the HTTPS part,
just the Yep. DNS.
A cube cluster name, could that be any
name? Any name. Yep. Alright. So let's do
Rawkode.
And that's it. Easy.
He says.
So that means we don't actually need these.
We can just do
that.
Where'd my terminal go?
You seem pretty good with that Mac, David.
Well, when I'm within Versus code in my
terminal, yeah, not much has to change. So
that's that's alright. Alright. Right. But
yeah. As a matter I have to actually
do anything with a moving window, then yeah.
Things get a little painful.
So
let's try.
Yeah. That should work.
My q config which is now there.
Alright. So that created a namespace.
We can run get pods,
and we'll run a watch on that. Already
almost there. Okay. Yeah. If we if we
look at the logs, we should see that
it it was able to connect
successfully.
So the logs
From here, what if you go back to
the command line, the t cuddle.
Oh, yeah. That's There you go. I got
it. I understand.
You can always do a get of cube
underscore service.
So that I don't think it's registered yet.
Let's let's go back and see.
Alright. Let's get the logs of this, see
what's going on.
Timed out trying to reach that IP address
and port.
Oh, and I think we do need to
set I don't I don't think we set
Unsecure? Yeah. Yeah. I think we need to
change that.
In the in the back in the values,
yeah, but you can it's there it is.
Insecure.
Yep. There we go.
Just
quickly remove that. It might be easier.
Maybe that.
Upgrade. Correct.
Do you think I might have trouble getting
that DNS?
No. It should be okay. And I don't
see anything from the logs that suggests an
error anymore.
So let's just try it like that.
Is it thinking about it?
Yeah. It's saying it TCP
timeout.
Oh. This
is the right one, isn't it?
We want dash k h t t p
s.
I mean, that's publicly accessible. Yeah. So
Do we wanna try the IP as well?
See if we can get to that.
Because you insecure, it really doesn't matter.
Yeah. Sure.
Start with the port number?
Yep.
Oh, yeah. Address to the Teleport proxy web
to port. Okay.
Yeah. A lot some people change it to
443.
I'm just gonna remove it.
It should start again.
Alright. Helm install.
Good.
From pods.
I'll grab the logs again.
User's unsecure.
It's alright. Is is that good or bad?
Failed to register to the off server invalid.
I can probably get a new value.
Oh, you know what it is? Where's
that helmets document?
Dash f.
Although it shouldn't matter because No. Shouldn't matter.
The chart. Now. Yeah. Shouldn't matter.
I thought I was onto something there. Yeah.
Yeah.
So it seems to be
I mean, that invalid character seems to be
like I'm not expecting
I think that's because well, it first it
first checks to see if that's the auth
server. If it's not, it should fall back,
but it should be able to connect to
that.
So
it's still getting the time out.
Is there a way we can test that
it is able to find that IP? Yeah.
I mean, I'll jump on that machine. So
let's do that.
So
one.
And then we want the IP address of
this one.
And
3080.
And then allow the and secure.
Yeah. I mean, that does work.
Yeah. For and our
for micro
Kubernetes, I know I just I didn't had
to install the DNS, but
I don't know if that's I assume that's
enabled.
Make sure I enabled networking on this thing.
It does. Yeah. It's got Calico running. Okay.
Let's try it from one of these pods
then. Yeah. So
which one of these will actually have something
I can get inside?
Well, let's try that one. Sure.
O dash I t
curl h t p s.
Oh, always. Yeah. I was gonna have like,
if that works. Yeah.
Let's see if we can get this command
in before the probes kick me out and
restart the container.
Oh, there's no networking. Yeah. That now I
think that's the issue.
Well, it's not good when I give you
a broken Kubernetes cluster, is it? Oh, no.
No. I well, getting that in yeah. With
micro, it's nice, but you always have to
add like, at the app bar back, you
have to add DNS. So I it doesn't
happen.
Alright. Then we get to play a game
of can I fix my Kubernetes cluster? So
let's see.
Why would that not work? Yeah. They're running.
That is peculiar.
I wonder if it is
I'm gonna just quickly do engine x.
I have had issues before where one namespace
has lost networking and I don't know why.
Oh, I see what you mean.
So I'm gonna apply that to the cluster
and the default namespace.
Assume that'll be up by now.
See if we can get a shell inside
of it.
That's got curls, so that's a good start.
No. Alright.
Fun. Let's try
delete
pod
l
k sap.
Calico.
Nope.
Oh, namespace.
Kube system
delete
pod
l.
I'm just assuming they use
this.
No.
System get pods.
Describe pod.
Cali cool.
Yep. Anyone will do. Hopefully, I got something
in common. I'm just gonna boot them and
see if that fixes it. Mhmm.
K sap calip. Oh, yeah.
So that one's different.
And call it called node. Okay. Let's try
that.
Okay.
System delete part
and
that was close.
Alright. That one gone.
And let's do calico node,
which should delete more. Alright.
Fingers crossed.
Let's just restart engine x just in case.
No curl.
What's the backup plan?
I mean, I I can show my environment,
you know, show show how that's how that's
working. Yeah.
Why is my cluster got no networking? I
mean, there isn't
do you think there's some kind of default
securities
policy? Or No. This is a vanilla Kubernetes
cluster I spun up this morning. Mhmm. I
just threw a calico on it.
There's nothing
on it that would be restricting network access.
Yeah. I mean, this is all very vanilla.
I guess
I could maybe Yeah. The other way is,
yeah, my a micro
Kubernetes quickly or
Well, do you have a working Kubernetes setup
and you're happy to share your screen? I've
got all that setup. Yeah. If I if
I can share it. I don't think it's
very interesting for people to watch me try
and fix my my very broken cluster. And
I really wanna see some more Teleport goodness.
So let's let's let's do that. Yeah.
It's a last stream with a few problems.
Yeah.
So I've I've I've gone ahead and this
this is a
Teleport instance installed in on eight FBOS with
the EC two.
I've got some this is the difference
you would have with, you know, the community
version you have
is that one of the things is you
can have multiple SSOs
configured,
and it can support multiple at the same
time, and you're just mapping it to individual
roles. What when yours was running,
you you all have essentially a single role,
of admin,
but you do have individual,
users.
So when I was saying about going back,
you can set into it like, remember, you
added your usernames.
You can set usernames. You can set Kubernetes
groups, Kubernetes users. So there are traits that
you can populate, and I'll show those traits
as part of the, login.
Now I I usually choose this one because
it's easy to be connected to my Google
account, and I don't have enter enter passwords.
And then we we have the set of
nodes available as we were talking before about
those labeling. So there's different different ways you
can do it, but there this way, you
have, you know, an ID.
You can also do dynamic.
Now in this case, I also have one
where
I've configured this to require Duo.
So this requires me to,
do a second factor.
Where's my duo?
So I have to approve it.
And the first time you come in, like,
you came at the Rawkode ID, it would
push you to go sign that up,
to make it a second factor. So every
different every user would have a different
second factor to confirm.
Now in terms of the applications,
because I have I have two configured, I
have a just a Hacker News, which forwards
directly to Hacker News, but it's using our,
you know, our certificate. As you mentioned, having
something in front of it, know, if it
was an HTTP or an insecure setting, you
could do that. And then you're you are
using a secure connection.
Otherwise, you know, in this case, I'm running
an Elastic,
service
behind
that my my machines that's not publicly available,
and then you then you can connect to
it directly.
So this is running just like with the
Kubernetes,
there's another app service running that uses an
app token and registers itself.
You can also put labeling on these to
say, well, not everyone can access this. I'm
gonna label this service, and only in your
role,
could you have access to that particular service.
Pretty cool.
Yep. Now in terms of the Kubernetes, and
I'll I'll because we were just in that,
I want to get to it. So this
is the type of configuration you usually have
where,
you know, you have a particular group come
in. In this case, I'm using external, so
I can use the meta tags from my
SSO to populate it,
and then labeling. Now in terms of your
individual user, you can put the same you
can put their groups in there as well.
So here, I went ahead and and logged
in locally.
Let me clear that because it's gonna be
a little confusing.
So this user maps to that dev role.
And when I see the status, I can
see my Kubernetes.
I can see what cluster I'm in, what
groups do I have,
and then my
you know, I I can look at,
you know, namespace,
because that that particular group has that permission,
but I I do not have
exact permission.
I
think it just denied it.
But, essentially, that's a way of, you know,
giving people default access,
like logging and watching as opposed to, you
know, just giving them system masters or, you
know you know, a lot more privilege than
they probably need. So that's typically how we
recommend setting it up. And then this user
can
they can request other roles that have that
kind of other namespace or other exact access.
Okay. So this YAML is just configuring all
of the RBAC for me on the Kubernetes
side. Yeah. And it and this is what
I mentioned before about the max connections,
and you can say whether or not someone
can port forward.
So in this case, if I look at
you know, my these are the nodes that
are available. And because it has that tiered
equal dev labeling,
that's restricting what nodes I've accessed just like
if I wanted to restrict well, they can't
see that elastic link,
I I can do it through that.
And then in this case, I do have
NGX server running here, so someone can
So I'm essentially saying I wanna open up
an SSH connection. I don't want it to
be interactive,
but I wanna forward I want my local
port eighty eighty to forward to their local
host 80 on that machine.
And then I'm seeing the web server on
that on that machine running locally.
But that is something you can turn off.
You don't have to give them access because
it's great to be able to do that,
but you don't always wanna give someone that
open access to beyond that node.
Alright.
Now another thing we mentioned was about, you
know, I said about PAM.
So each of these environments, and this is
also I'll I'll show you example of that
BPF we were talking about.
This environment has that this machine has that
enabled.
So every command I'm doing
is being logged here, the session command,
which includes the arguments,
you know, the path.
And this is available in the OSS version.
It's not Pacific Enterprise. So any anyone can
install that and the PAM
as well as it's auto creating my user.
So if you look at if you look
at the Teleport
configuration,
I have PAM enabled, and I say go
to this service name.
And I'm saying where to where to get
what what to execute when this PAM
loaded.
And so this enters into this environment.
It will check to see if the user
exists or not. If they don't exist, it
it automatically creates it, including some headers like
you wanna create a home, things like that.
And then I have some additional checking here
where this is actually adding them. It's looking
in their Teleport role that come in and
says, okay. Based on their role,
add them or or don't add them to
the SIS admin group to give them that
pseudo rights. So that's something something you could
do as well as have those kind of
scripting built in.
Nice.
But, yeah, this this is so and then
all all of these things you're seeing here,
that is being fed, you know, in real
time into my Elastic service. So That's part
of part of why I usually have that
running.
It's gonna it's gonna look ugly because I
haven't made it pretty yet, but, you know,
all that data is coming in. So every
log entry is going in.
Is that something you have to build custom
or does Teleport support various syncs for for
that stuff like that? Well, it there's
it writes to
you can have it two ways. One is
it can write to the directory files on
your on your auth service
as well as writing to, like, DynamoDB.
You can have it do both too.
So if you have a log aggregator that
you all you don't like, yeah, DynamoDB is
great, but I don't wanna write a Lambda.
You could just have a file a log
aggregator running locally. I'm using Filebeat.
Alright. Okay. Pretty, yeah, pretty simple configuration.
And, essentially,
you know, you just you just look for
the log files. They're JSON formatted as you
saw here,
and you just pass that through,
you know, to Elastic and Kibana.
The only part I didn't do a lot
of security again, so that's why why I
wanna hide it behind this and not necessarily,
you know, have all all all that good
stuff. Can you just show the add application
dialogue? I mean, how easy is it to
add new applications? Okay.
Let's see.
I'll just do it.
Okay. Two.
We'll just point back to itself.
So this, I would, you know, just run
run on a particular machine.
And one second. I'll
I have a machine here I can use.
Sorry. I was
doing nerd stuff by myself.
So I've seen when you were doing that
that add application dialogue, there was the automatic
which has some sort of curl scripted version
of doing this and there was manual.
So What's that?
When you run that application, this was the
automatic way. This this curl command, there was
also manual steps. What's actually happening to proxy
one of these applications? Is it doing something
on a host? Like Yeah. I mean, it's
it's acting as
a a proxy for it.
Essentially, this is running as a separate just
like the SSH service, it's running as a
separate agent.
And then it's it's able to then from
this particular node,
it's this is where you would get the
access. You know, it's doing the DNS connection
to that to that service.
And does that work differently for Kubernetes services?
Is it It's just it's just actually the
same concept.
I mean, the I'd say the biggest difference
is
when we're running inside of,
you know, Kubernetes,
we're
you know, when Teleport
is
impersonating
a
user
or group
within Kubernetes,
it's just the difference in
for the app access, it's actually connecting out
to another application. So we're not running inside
that application,
but we're we're a lot we're essentially providing
the forwarding to it.
We do also send in a j JWS
token, a JSON web token, so that can
be used for automatic authentication.
Alright.
Let's see. I think
sorry. I didn't I didn't clear this environment
previously.
Sorry. I thought that was a different environment.
Sorry about that.
So now I've added that,
and we can see that has shown up.
I'm just pointing back at myself, but it's
not really loud. But yeah.
And if we look at what it did
let's let's see what
that added that app service here. It added
the auth token, the CA pin. We talked
about that before.
It's opened up a connection to the auth
server,
and let's make that a little more friendly.
So another way I could do this is
just by modifying my Teleport.YAML
and filling that apps array at the bottom
with whatever I wanted to proxy. Right? Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. I'd say the big the biggest
difference why you'd wanna run that in different
locations is, again,
you know, who has access to what? Where
is it accessing? Because not every node has
access to the same set of services. You
know, as you said before, there may be
something you wanna expose from a specific machine.
So you would you would you would,
add add that in.
Alright. Thanks. Very cool.
Yeah. Sorry sorry I didn't have that up
and running already.
I brought a broken Kubernetes cluster to the
party. So
Yep.
Is there anything else you you'd like to
show us before we wrap up? Oh, I
keep going back to this. This is a
bad I
mean, essentially, you know, the the other
part was in terms of our our cloud
interaction,
and, essentially, it's the same
very similar environment. In this case, I've got
I've already got a cloud deployed here.
I configure with off zero.
So with the cloud product, like, because it's
using Auth0, that can connect to, like, my
GitHub and Google authentication and all these other
things. Yeah. It And it's the same version.
It's five five o o.
You know, we're it's we it is a,
you know, software service,
but we're maintaining the same version. I'd say
the the one of the minor differences is
that we we use reverse tunneling by default
for your SSH.
So instead of exposing
a port as you saw, like the thirty
twenty two, it would always be a reverse
tunnel. That way, we don't have to worry
about you opening
to your network or v p you know,
VPC, any of those kind of complications.
And just like before, I'm I'm in this
environment,
and I I can open up
Open up connections. Again, I use I use
the PAM configuration, so it automatically created my
user if it wasn't there.
So a lot a lot of people find
that very useful. Yep. So they don't have
to worry about creating users or or changing
their permissions.
But, yeah, we're we're just we're just, starting
to bring clients on the cloud.
And part of it is, you know, as,
you know, we've seen, we we think this
is a lot faster way to get things
up and going,
and it makes, you know again, you can
use those add server buttons, the add application
buttons, and it makes it makes it a
lot faster, you know, from your environment to
do those as opposed to having to install
the proxy and the auth.
We're we're just gonna maintain that for you.
Alright. Very cool. K.
So I I mean,
I
think I've just been impressed so many times
now. Like, there's a lot of really cool
features. I'm I'm struggling in my head to
think why I wouldn't want to be running
a Teleport in my cluster now or even
any of my infrastructure
with the security benefits and the all the
authentication and rules and groups and stuff. Like,
it's a pretty solid setup. Great. Yeah. No.
I appreciate that view and, Tom, I I
think there then there's, you know, you have
the developers that wanna use it because they're
gonna be moving through environments, deploying things.
You might have service users that you want
to migrate migrate various resources or access them,
and then, you know, tracking activity. Like, I
mean, auditors usually love us because what did
you do in that machine? What did you
do in that Kubernetes?
You know, when when were you logging in?
Why did you have 10 sessions open? So
all of those things really, really help. But
as you see, it's, you know, you can
do one or two commands and get a
get a SSH node available,
and that's that can be really helpful, especially
if you're in a, you know, production outage
Yeah. You know, being able to get that
access but securely.
Alright. Awesome. Well, thank you for joining me
today and walking me through that and the
demo at the end was definitely appreciated as
well. Was good to see that running in
the Kubernetes context and how that works with
restricting the access to namespaces and exact permissions.
Like, there's just lots lots to love about
this product. So thank you for joining me
and taking the time to show us it
today. Thank you, David. Really appreciate it. Alright.
Well, you have a great rest of your
day. Thank you again and I'll speak to
you again soon. Thank you. Okay. Bye.